good evening everyone
it's an honor for us to be here tonight
and pay tribute
to a gifted artist
and a deeply compassionate activist
angelina julie
[Applause]
you know
when i first met
angelina
i recognized a brave artist
and a compassionate artist
and a warm and loving friend
you know she didn't have to come to
bosnia and she didn't have to cast us
local cast
and
she didn't have to make a film about the
bosnian war
but she did
she did
because she's a true artist
and a citizen of the world
who reminds us of those we have
forgotten
of those we have abandoned
of those that need our help
when the casting director said to me she
likes you a lot i ask who likes me a lot
and
and she said angelina jolie
and then i said ah
angelina jolie so don't you lie to me
you know
because being an actor from belgrade you
don't expect to get that kind of uh
offer quite often you know so
it was a winning of in lottery
she brought actors from both sides of
the conflict
and
she made them play together
and
she made us same the same story to tell
the same story
for those of us who lived
through the war
she gave us the opportunity to express
ourselves
and for that i am deeply grateful to you
angie
because of the reputation
and the respect she has earned
internationally this honor is not just
for angelina the filmmaker
but for the contribution she has made
and still makes
outside
of her film work
and for the good she does
around the world
what angelina has done is extraordinary
because she is extraordinary her status
in the film industry has afforded her a
unique opportunity to take on a legion
of global issues
she's given her heart to those who
suffer the world's most shattering
violence
and victimization
and given voice to those who struggle to
live
with dignity
and hope
angelina is
proof of the power we all have to make a
difference
so let us for a moment take a look at
this most remarkable woman
who questions not
how
or why she does this but rather
how could she not